Avengers age of Ultron is one of the
most anticipated films of the entire
year not just for movie fans but
especially for us comic-book fans who
enjoy seeing our heroes treated well on
the screen because the first Avengers
film did that marvelously in my opinion
doing this movie stark and banner
accidentally create an artificial
intelligence life-form known as Ultron
the original plan was to help protect
the earth with that invention but things
go awry when its idea of protecting the
earth isn't quite what stark had in mind
once Ultron gains consciousness and
starts to take control of various things
the Avengers have to unite once again to
stop this guy from destroying the earth
now you may think I've kind of seen that
before in a way and you'd be right it's
really easy to level criticisms at this
movie saying that it takes certain plot
points from the first one and tries to
do the same thing again but you can't
really have an Avengers movie without a
gigantic army because it was just one
guy than to be like seven people just
punching one guy in the face and it
wouldn't really be that interesting you
kind of need an army for the Avengers to
fight and I can honestly tell you this
is the most fun I've had at the movies
so far in 2015 this movie is filled to
the brim with incredible action
sequences but it's all handled great I
mean the shots look fantastic the CGI is
virtually seamless there isn't that one
shot where you go yeah that's computer
right there I mean you know it's
computer but it doesn't affect your
appreciation of it I could go on and on
just about the Hulkbuster scene in
general but let's talk about the things
that really matter in this movie and
what that is is the characters you go to
these movies for those characters those
are really the most important thing and
Whedon has once again crafted excellent
excellent dialogue for these guys to
banter with the arguments they have are
truly hilarious the dialogue is still
very witty and very funny his humor is
laced throughout this entire movie and
it's very welcomed you go to these
movies for the characters and for the
action and those two things are handled
so well that I couldn't help but have a
lot of fun with this movie despite some
flaws so let's talk about some of those
flaws because this is not a perfect
movie and my opinion it is not quite as
good as the first Avengers in fact I
think Winter Soldier is even better than
this film it is still a marvelously good
time though Ultron's
presence as a villain is actually very
funny he's a bit of a sarcastic villain
actually which I did not expect and
actually really enjoyed that being said
though his creation and how we get to
him being Ultron was so rushed and it
felt like there was probably like 10 to
15 minutes of scenes missing from the
movie that would have helped us
understand Ultron as a character more
because he's created and then all of a
sudden he's just there and he's being
bad and you're like something should
have happened to get us to this point
emotionally which leads me to the fact
that Whedon has actually acknowledged
his original cut for this movie was over
three hours long and that the Avengers
blu-ray is going to have an extended cut
as well as an alternate ending which is
awesome but I feel like there are a lot
of things that have been removed from
this movie to get it back down to two
and a half hours and it makes the entire
thing feel a little rushed from time to
time
the addition of Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver they're fine they're fine
characters but they weren't really that
entertaining put silver and Days of
Future past was much better this time
around these characters are very wounded
very serious there are certain plot
points that are brought up about their
past
that's not resolved or really ever
mentioned again and one of the biggest
challenges that Marvel faces now is the
fact that all these movies are very
episodic in nature they all have to tie
into each other in some way and so there
are certain scenes throughout this movie
and there are other films that are
needed to help explain things that
happen previously or that are going to
happen in upcoming movies and they
sometimes come off as contractually
obligated scenes like a scene where Thor
visits this well that doesn't really fit
in this film but makes sense for what's
coming up and Thor Ragnarok it's just
that in this film you feel like is that
what is this really what's this doing
here and those are really my only issues
with this film the most important part
of the Avengers movies in my opinion is
getting the characters correct and my
gosh Joss Whedon just nails it the
chemistry between these characters is so
real and is still there it might even be
better than in the first film there's
also way more of an attempt to humanize
Hawkeye in this movie to make him more
than just the cool guy with a bow and
arrow and that was really cool it was
great to see more attention given these
characters a slightly more complex
character building plot throughout this
movie and the added complexity of humor
and backstory and things like that
really gave a lot more to these
characters and made them seem more like
you
beings and less like superheroes which I
thought was really really great and I
could gush about the action all day
because it is handled so well there's
tons of it it's really a comic book fans
dream to see these guys on screen
together and we can get kind of
inundated with all these comic book
movies nowadays and forget the fact that
we are actually getting the privilege to
live in a time where we can see Iron Man
Captain America Hulk Black Widow and all
these people on screen at once let's not
take that for granted
that's pretty awesome and Joss Whedon
did a very good job molding these
characters and making them very likable
despite the fact that the plot is a
little bit rushed and Ultron as a
villain does not have the type of origin
that allows us to really get into his
character that he should and really
quickly I'm not going to talk too much
about this character because you don't
know that much about him I don't want to
spoil too much but I really liked Paul
Bettany as vision I really did I think
he's a very cool character and I can't
wait to see where else they go with him
so despite some of the plot issues the
overabundance of characters that can
sometimes get a little jumbled and the
rushed feel of some aspects of this
movie I honestly had a blast with
Avengers age of Ultron and I think if
you are a comic book fan and a fan of
these types of things in general you can
look past some of these issues just
recognize it's not going to be as good
as the first film I'm going to give
Avengers age of Ultron a B+ guys I
cannot wait for you to experience this
movie on the big screen in the theater
and please actually go see it in the
theater don't watch it online don't do
that just just go to the movie and
experience this on the big screen like
it should be and if you don't want to go
to the theater wait for the blu-ray
support these guys they're making good
entertainment
give him a few bucks speaking of
supporting people like me I'm doing a
promotion right now with space wolf
limited these guys have been really
awesome to me they're artists from
Brooklyn New York who do incredible
laser-engraved posters on would they
have ghost in the shell' artwork as you
guys know I love and he plants a tree
for every piece sold and he's already
planted over 1500 of them if you use the
coupon code stuckman you can get 25% off
anything in his site and they're
sponsoring this video and I want to
thank them for that and thank you guys
for watching if you go to space wolf
limited comm and use the coupon codes
Tuchman you can get 25% off anything in
their store thanks so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here
and get stuck man eyes